one of the best Sinatra stories
ever is that guy when he went to
Australia some feminist over there gave
him a bad review and then he called her
at the uh Sydney Opera House tell me he
her dude no
oh that would have been nuts
dude I don't know if this story could
talk that tell me the dude he
called her a $3
at the at the show at the show and
then it got out and and then there was
this big backlash so the Prime Minister
was saying you have to apologize to her
and he's like I'm not apologizing so
then they came back and said if you
don't apologize we're not going to allow
you to leave the country so now he's
holed up in his penthouse suite and he
says to his lawyers he's pouring a drink
he goes well I'm not apologizing so now
what and it was like the Cuban Missile
Crisis they were just sitting up there
they figured out some wiggle room where
they could both be happy and he end up
leaving and then he came back he's like
I'm never going back to that
piece of country again